le césar du meilleur premier film est
attribué à des garçons et guillaume à
table
c'était la toute première nomination sa
carrière dans ce film autobiographique
il raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme
qu'est ce que dans sa propre sexualité
qui se persuade les qu'une fille et que
son entourage quand homosexuels il
s'agit de l'adaptation de sa propre
pièce dans laquelle il atteint prêter
tous les rôles le film a triomphé en
salle avec plus de deux millions cinq
cent mille entrées il a été découvert à
la quinzaine des réalisateurs puis primé
au festival d'angoulême sarlat ou encore
de la meilleure pour lui ce film d'une
déclaration femmes en général et à sa
mère en particulier
s'il y en a qui a le droit et même le
devoir de remercier sa mère là pour le
coup c'est moi
donc merci maman pour m'avoir donné
beaucoup plus que le titre
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de gens à
remercier d'abord évidemment vous tous
merci infiniment
j'assimile odeo débute cette histoire
c'est grâce à un monsieur qui s'appelle
olivier meyer équité qui dirige le
théâtre de l'ouest parisien boulogne
c'est grâce à lui que j'ai pu écrire
cette histoire et la jouer et puis
ensuite mis en scène par claude mathieu
maraine qui m'a suivi tout le tournage
mais d'abord avec son mari nicolas fait
ce qu'il fallait cris tueur merci à
xavier giannoli aussi qui m'a beaucoup
aidé pour l'adaptation et puis merci à
mes producteurs je comprends pas
pourquoi vous monte pas sur scène en
fait parce que meilleur film
il monte voilà donc edouard weil éveil
pour rectangle si ricol beau justin jean
baptiste dupont pour lg m
c'est grâce à vous
s'est désolé monsieur le président
d'avoir pris longtemps ce pour protocole
mai
voilà voilà
edouard weil si l'alcool beau justin
jean baptiste dupont merci vous le
méritez autant que moi alors je vais pas
leur laisser la parole puisque je suis
très bavard mais mais du coup je vais
directement remercier évidemment ceux
grâce à qui ont ils ont pu financer donc
si denis dumas gaumont merci merci à
toutes les équipes de gaumont françois
clerc ariane toscan toutes vos équipes
merci canal + france racine et plus
merci et puis ben le film c'est surtout
évidemment les les artistes les acteurs
et les techniciens et j'ai eu une chance
incroyable parce que j'ai j'ai eu des
gens extrêmement généreux qui n'ont pas
essayé de m'imposer leur égo leurs
fantasmes qui visiblement voulez
vraiment savoir ce qu'il y avait dans ma
tête
probablement parce que cette histoire
était personnelle mais ils ont été plus
que généreux avec moi et puis et puis
merci évidemment évidemment merci à ma
femme parce que sans toi y aurait pas eu
cette révolution dans tous les sens du
terme et était plus qu'une résolution
merci merci infiniment